[Musique]
c'est un drame qui est survenu vendredi
soir à 21h lors du festival a trouvé au
texas
alors que ce festival organisé par le
rappeur crévits scott accueilli près de
58 participants un moment fou le
spectaculaire a provoqué la mort de huit
personnes et fait plus d'une vingtaine
de blessés des gens ont commencé à
tomber à perdre connaissance
et cela a créé une panique
supplémentaires plusieurs plaintes ont
été déposées à l'encontre des chanteurs
prédit scott et drake qui n'ont à aucun
moment arrêter le concert alors que les
débordements étaient nombreux
cette affaire a suscité l'émotion à
travers la planète et sur les réseaux
sociaux pourtant keen'v s'est servi de
ce fait divers pour en plaisanter sur
tik tok je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
tout ce que chef c'est que il ya eu plus
de morts à son concert que de gens qui
viennent me voir moi au moins avec moi
vous êtes en sécurité une vidéo qui a
été mal perçu de la part de nombreux
internautes alors comprenez vous les
critiques après la blague de keen'v
bon endroit alors c'est vrai que keen v
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des morts
il ya eu huit mois mais bien sûr mais
moi je trouve ça marrant parce que c'est
rare de voir un artiste avec autant
d'autodérision oui il ya eu des morts
bien sûr que c'est grave maintenant
c'est quelque chose qui s'est produit à
dix mille kilomètres d'ici on n'est pas
en données nationales non plus mais
d'accord mais il a droit de faire des
vannes oui mais moins d'un mois
s'énervait et voilà je trouve pas je
trouvais ça marrant c'est que c'est un
7e tour avec un petit peu trop violent
voilà que maintenant me voilà la vanne
mauvais goût je pense qu'il est venu là
titre et ça va mal et pas très drôle a
pas quand on connaît un peu qui ne vais
je pense qu'il ya un gars sont plus
gentils noms mais il n'y a pas plus
jeune est sûre ça tourne effectivement
ai pas beaucoup d'artistes en général
ils tous je reporte cette prouesse qu'on
peut sortir des vannes sur tout
d'habitude on en a eu tellement mais tu
les fais en privé mais ouais mais ce
garçon est tellement c'est ce que si la
france est vraiment c'est ça oui kelly
mal et généralement quand on est touché
par ce genre de blague c'est qu'on sait
que la famille peut entendre çà et là
sincèrement je pense pas que les
familles ont entendu qu'il ne me vois
pas où est le problème c'était une
blague de mauvais goût mais il n'y a pas
de quoi s'en offusquer français pas
introuvable c'est la ville et fait
d'excès sur l'autodérision qu'il fallait
retenir mais la juge et madame après
trop d'autodérision sur l'autodérision
tout je pense que tout le monde a raison
c'est à dire que c'est maladroit c'est
un peu raté moi je suis beaucoup plus
choqué des artistes aux états unis qui
continuent de gens
qui sont en train de crever ça c'est
choquant ceci nous ayons spatial il ya
quand même une autre version c'est qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup de vidéos tu vois les
artistes en train de dire calmez vous
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est que c'est
en train de se changer tout ça ils sont
pas au courant ils ne sont pas au
courant de ce qui se passe en direct et
julia aussi beaucoup que vous ayez vidéo
des trucs de satanistes des trucs de fin
à sa part un peu dans tous les sens ils
veulent pas mal tout comme ça rappelle
toi le rappelle
ils ont joué le match de foot d'ailleurs
exactement il a raison